I'm going on a date with my boyfriend.
I really like this bodysuit,
and I got these little,
like, sleeves from the TikTok shop.
Help me pick out which one I should wear.
Look how cute it is, though,
because you still can, like,
show off the cuteness of your bodysuit.
But be warm.
Okay, there's this color and then this color.
Oh, I like the light one.
Oh, I like this.
It kind of makes it more obvious
that I'm wearing a shirt,
because otherwise
it does look like I'm kind of a unique.
And I like it,
cause if you're wearing a not long necklace
that kind of pokes under, or you can put it on top.
Okay, number one or number two?
It came in a two pack.
If you like it,
it's linked right here.
I think I'm gonna do this one. Okay.